[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Good afternoon everyone,
and welcome to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean here at
the Institute, and I
am delighted to welcome
you to Radcliffe,
an institution powered
by the same commitment
to ideas and discovery
that HUBweek celebrates.
HUBweek, a civic collaboration
between the Boston Globe, MIT,
Mass General
Hospital, and Harvard,
showcases innovation
and creativity
at the intersection of art,
science, and technology.
The purpose of
HUBweek aligns closely
with Radcliffe's
own dual mission
of fostering advanced work
that transcends disciplines
and sharing that work
with the public, with you.
In addition to serving as
dean of this institute,
I wear a second hat as
a professor of history
and American studies at Harvard.
And today, I'm delighted
to tip both my dean's hat
and my professorial
hat to Professor Carol
Oja, my colleague
in American studies
and a fellow at the Radcliffe
Institute this year.
And Carol will deliver
this afternoon's lecture,
as you know.
I realize that today may
be the first introduction
to the Radcliffe
Institute for many of you.
So I'd like to
just take a moment
to explain a bit more about
who we are and what we do.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe is one
of the 13 schools
that make up Harvard University.
As I mentioned a moment ago,
we carry out a dual mission.
First, we cultivate a uniquely
interdisciplinary intellectual
community, in which faculty
and students from Harvard
and leading thinkers
from around the world all
engage in scholarship,
scientific investigation,
and the creative arts
across many academic fields.
And second, we are
dedicated to sharing
cutting edge work
with the public
by hosting free events
like today's lecture,
and then posting videos of
our lectures and conferences
on our Radcliffe website.
We pursue our dual mission
through three core programs.
The first of our core programs
is our Radcliffe fellowship
program.
Every year, we bring 50
scholars, scientists,
and artists to campus
as Fellows to work
at the forefront
of their fields and
across disciplinary boundaries.
Today's speaker, Carol Oja is
this year's Frieda L. Miller
Fellow, and I'm very pleased to
have Frieda Miller's son, Myron
Miller, here with us today.
The Frieda Miller Fellowship
was established in Frieda's name
by Myron's late
father, Herman Miller,
to honor Frieda's passionate
belief in higher education.
And I have to say that I
have a special affection
for the Miller
Fellowship, for the Miller
family and the fellowship,
because the Frieda L. Miller
gift was, in fact, the gift
that funded my Radcliffe
Fellowship when I was a
Radcliffe Fellow in 2001 too.
In addition to Carol,
this year's Fellows
include leading thinkers from
six different continents.
They are studying
everything from the origins
of the universe, to marvels
in late medieval literature,
to human rights
in Latin America.
And this year's
artists are creating
everything from sculptures,
to poems, to operas.
Our second major program
is the Schlesinger Library,
which is the foremost
library dedicated
to the history of women and
gender in the United States.
Recently, the library has
made a substantial commitment
to telling the fullest,
most inclusive story
of the American
past by taking steps
to diversify our holdings to
include collections from women
and organizations across every
racial class, geographical,
and political divide.
To that end, the
Schlesinger Library
will be holding a
panel discussion
called "Righting the Record," on
Monday, October 17th, at 4:15.
This program will consider
the challenges and the rewards
of collecting the papers
of political conservatives
and their organizations.
It will be moderated
by Ross Douthat, who's
a columnist at the
New York Times.
Our third program we
call academic ventures,
and it hosts an array of
conferences, lectures,
exhibitions, and
performances that
are all open to the public.
For example, on Thursday,
October 13th at 4:15,
we'll be sponsoring a
panel discussion called
"Families in Flight,"
which will explore today's
international refugee crisis.
And I think you have a card
for that, the yellow card,
on your seat.
Our annual full day
science symposium
will take place on
Friday, October 28,
beginning at 9:00 AM.
This year's symposium
is entitled "From Sea
to Changing Sea," and
it will investigate
the world's endangered oceans.
And I'm just going to
mention one more event.
You have the calendar cards
that will tell you about more.
But I think this may interest
the audience we have here
today.
Garth Risk Hallberg, who
is the author of a widely
acclaimed novel
called City on Fire,
set in New York
City in the 1970s.
And he will be
talking about his book
and about the challenges
of writing fiction
about a specific time and place.
That will take place on
Tuesday, November 15th.
All of these events
will take place here
at the Knafel Center, along
with many others, as I said,
that are listed on that card.
You can also visit our website
and learn about our calendar.
And there, you can register
for lectures and conferences
and watch videos
of previous events.
So I hope we will see you
often in the year ahead.
All these events are free
and open to the public.
But in many cases, we
ask you to register ahead
so we can be sure to
accommodate the audience.
The Radcliffe Institute
is a busy place.
But no matter how
busy, the heart
of any institute
for advanced study
is it's fellowship program.
And I'm very pleased to offer
you this glimpse into ours
through the work of
our Fellow, Carol Oja.
Carol is a scholar of
musicology, history,
and literature.
She's also a star
teacher, which I
happen to know because I
have seen her in action.
One semester, and
this was actually
quite a number of
years ago already,
I was teaching a graduate class
on the City in 20th Century
American Culture, and
Carol was teaching
another graduate seminar
in the music department.
And we brought our
classes together
for a session on Shuffle Along,
a 1920s musical featuring
an all African American cast.
During that joint
class, I was extremely
impressed by Carol's talent
for operating on two scales.
She drew students
deep into discussion
about how each
chord and each lyric
was the product of the
composer's deliberate
decisions.
But she also never lost sight
of the larger historical context
in which those
choices were made.
Her probing questions
revealed critical insights
into the racial politics
of New York in the 1920s.
Much like her teaching,
Carol's repertoire
of written scholarship
operates on two registers
and in multiple keys.
In her book, Making
Music Modern,
she examines the artistic
and historic forces at work
in New York's creative
explosion of the 1920s.
Like a pianist's fingers working
to produce rich harmonic tones,
her prose moves nimbly from
probing the composition
of melody on the one
hand to assessing
the impact of
international politics
on cultural production
on the other.
In her book, Bernstein
Meets Broadway,
Carol follows the
Boston-born Leonard Bernstein
from his boyhood here in the hub
through the social and cultural
politics of the US at war.
She remains attentive
to each sharp and flat
in Bernstein's score to his
hit musical On the Town,
and at the same time, she
never forgets the tragedy
of a Japanese-American Broadway
star enchanting audiences
while her father languished
in an internment camp.
Nor does she overlook
the bitter irony
of African-American performers
finally making their way
into integrated orchestras
and chorus lines,
even as African-American
GIs in World War II
remained barred from any
fighting military units
and from any public
accommodations
throughout the United States.
Now today, Carol will be
sharing with us some new work.
She will take a close look
at the role of concert singer
Marian Anderson in the long
fight against segregation
in the United States.
This talk is part of Carol's
fellowship project, an inquiry
into the racial politics of
classical music performance
in post-war America.
That project is a
striking illustration
of exactly the sort of
interdisciplinary study
that we at Radcliffe
strive to make possible.
Carol's work, like that
of many of our Fellows,
crosses those traditional
disciplinary boundaries
to help us see and understand
the world in new ways.
So now, I ask you to please
join me in welcoming Carol Oja.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thanks, Liz.
It was a very
generous introduction.
And I'm really grateful to be
here at Radcliffe this year.
It seems like just a small
and short step across Mass Ave
from the music department.
But in fact, it's a
pretty big distance
in terms of just
how my time is spent
and in terms of meeting
a new group of people
with the other
Fellows at Radcliffe.
Memory shifts over time, as
does the collective perception
of who constitutes a
major historical figure,
and what events are viewed
as cultural landmarks.
Not so long ago,
a concert given by
the great African-American
contralto, Marian Anderson,
on the steps of the
Lincoln Memorial in 1939
was hailed widely as a
catalyzing event in the Civil
Rights Movement.
It was routine to
narratives of the struggle,
and it served as a visual
and strategic prelude
to the March on Washington,
when Martin Luther King
Jr. delivered his famous, "I
Have a Dream," speech in 1963.
Anderson's extraordinary
outdoor performance
was the first massive
staging of passive resistance
on behalf of civil rights
at the Lincoln Memorial.
And the concert attracted
a racially integrated crowd
of some 75,000 people.
A new design for the $5 bill
which was announced last spring
honors that history.
It will retain
Lincoln on the front,
but be reworked on the back
to feature historic events
at the memorial.
Marian Anderson will
be part of that scheme,
together with Martin Luther
King and First Lady Eleanor
Roosevelt.
Even though Anderson will
be one of the first women
to appear on US paper
money in a very long time,
and even though she is among
the first African Americans ever
to be represented there, she is
far less known today than once
was the case.
When the new $5
bill was announced
by Secretary of the
Treasury, Jacob Lew,
Newsweek ran a story titled,
"Who is Marian Anderson?"
giving a vivid sense of
how memories are fading.
In Secretary Lew's
press release,
he described Anderson as "a
world-renowned opera singer."
And today, I want to query
that characterization.
World-renowned is apt, but
opera is deeply problematic
given the fact that Anderson,
like all gifted black
performers of her day,
faced structural segregation
in the country's
opera houses, indeed,
in most of its institutions
of elite musical culture.
This afternoon, I will
start by exploring
a few highly publicized
moments in Anderson's career,
viewing them in relation
to segregationist practices
in the concert venues
where she performed.
My ultimate focus will be to
shape a contextual history
of Anderson's debut
at the Metropolitan
Opera in New York
City, which took place
on January 7th, 1955.
It was the first time
that a singer of color
was featured by that
internationally-recognized
company since its
founding in 1880.
With Marian Anderson, there's
a solid literature, much of it
indebted to a rich biography
of Allan Keiler from Brandeis.
Wallace Cheatham has also
been an important figure
in chronicling the history
of black opera singers.
My goal is to shift
the angle of inquiry
to focus on racial practices
in the American infrastructure
of classical music, and the
impact of those practices
on gifted performers
like Anderson.
So first, let's get
acquainted, or for some of you,
I'm sure, acquainted,
with Marian Anderson.
One of the most widely
acclaimed performers
of the mid-20th century,
Anderson attained
a degree of celebrity
that's hard to grasp today,
since classical music
no longer occupies
the same broad-based
popularity in American culture.
Born in 1897, she launched
her career in the early 1920s
and retired in 1965.
I'm just going to
pause over that,
because that is a
very long career.
She first came to attention
in the white concert world
in 1925, when she won a
vocal competition sponsored
by the National Musical League
at the New York Philharmonic's
Stadium Concerts, a summertime
outdoor series in Lewisohn
Stadium at City
College in Harlem.
By doing so, Anderson defied
every racial inclusion in place
at the time, winning
the competition
through the force of her talent.
As a result, she made a
debut with the Philharmonic
at the stadium that same
summer, and the stadium concerts
became a site for
desegregation overall.
Open air venues seemed
more amenable to change
than the close confines
of an indoor hall.
The depth of Anderson's talent
was proclaimed time and again,
most famously by the Italian
conductor Arturo Toscanini,
who after hearing her
perform in Salzburg in 1935,
declared that she had a voice
so exceptional as to appear
only once in 100 years.
Toscanini was quoted frequently
in the ensuing decades
as superlatives flowed from
the critical establishment.
Anderson sang for kings and
queens and American presidents.
She filled concert halls
and open air stadiums,
often jam-packed to the
limits of fire regulations.
She toured the
country and the world,
giving an astounding number
of concerts each year.
And she recorded prodigiously,
and was a regular fixture
on the radio, with television
appearances as well.
In short, Anderson
became a superstar,
with autograph seekers
lining up after her concerts.
In 1941, there were reportedly
27 Marion Anderson fan clubs
across the United States.
Yet she achieved
this popular acclaim
within the largely white
classical music business.
Performers who made their
living by interpreting music
from the revered
European tradition
were almost exclusively
of European descent.
Segregation also held firm in
the country's leading music
conservatories, which
only gradually started
to admit black students.
And in fact, Marian
Anderson never
studied at any of the
major conservatories.
It wasn't impossible.
Hiring practices and systems
of critical evaluation
were racially determined,
with white performers
assumed as the norm.
This is not only the
case in the South,
but also in the
urban North, notably
in New York City, the epicenter
of American classical music.
In a minute, we will hear
Marian Anderson in 1951
performing "Der Erlkonig,"
a renowned 19th century art
song by Franz Schubert, which
became one of her greatest
hits.
Franz Rupp is at the piano.
He became Anderson's
accompanist in 1941,
and the two worked together
until the end of her career.
Set to a poem by
Goethe, "Der Erlkonig"
tells a story of a father who
carries his son on horseback
in a terrifying ride.
The son senses an evil spirit,
and the father repeatedly
reassures him that it's
a natural phenomenon,
such as the wind, or in the
excerpt you're about to hear,
the ancient willows.
The conclusion is
devastating, with the child
suddenly dead in
his father's arms.
The performer of
"Der Erlkonig" needs
to have the dramatic
capacity to depict
four characters, a narrator,
the father, the son,
and the Erlking.
Shifting ranges are
key to conveying
the different
personalities, and the song
has mostly been identified
with male performers.
For Anderson, as a contralto,
meaning a low alto,
"Der Erlkonig"
offered an opportunity
to showcase the tremendous
range of her voice,
including its beautiful
lower registers.
It also displayed
the deep empathy
of her interpretive talent.
This excerpt includes the
shattering conclusion.
[MUSIC PLAYING - MARIAN
ANDERSON, "DER ERLKONIG"]
-[SINGING IN GERMAN]
-Thus, Anderson was
known to music lovers
around the world as recitalist.
Before tackling the
vexed term of "opera,"
let's explore her most
famous historical moment
which, in many ways, defined
her career and her public image.
This, of course, was the
concert at the Lincoln Memorial
on Easter Sunday in 1939.
Through an intense get out the
crowd Initiative by the NAACP,
Anderson performed to
an enormous mixed race
audience, a sea of
diversity that stretched out
from the memorial.
A headline in the New
York Herald Tribune
described her concert as
"the biggest assemblage
since the welcome of
Lindbergh in 1927."
Just a few months before the
event, Anderson's manager,
Sol Hurok, perhaps the
most powerful such figure
in performance
business at the time,
had attempted to book
a concert for her
at Constitution Hall in
Washington DC, which was then
the District's central
performance facility, home
to the National Symphony
Orchestra and the Washington
Opera.
This was three decades before
the opening of the Kennedy
Center for the Performing Arts.
Constitution Hall was
owned by the Daughters
of the American Revolution,
and its management
turned down Hurok's request,
claiming that the facility was
already booked.
In fact, the DAR was enforcing
the whites-only clause
in its contract.
By that point in
her career, Anderson
had performed in the
great concert facilities
of Europe and the US.
Her exclusion on
the basis of race
was taken up by
Walter White of NAACP,
who worked in
close collaboration
with Hurok, using
Anderson's case
to contest the widespread
segregation of concert
venues and other public spaces.
An intense lobbying
campaign ensued,
and a Marion Anderson
Committee was
formed, with Charles H.
Houston, a prominent NAACP
litigator as its attorney.
First Lady Eleanor Roosevelt
famously resigned from the DAR
in protest.
And Harold Ickes, then
Secretary of the Interior,
took up the cause, which
led to locating the event
at the Lincoln Memorial.
As Ickes put it, in introducing
Anderson at the concert,
"the Memorial was
a great auditorium
under the sky, in which
all of us are free."
The Chicago Defender,
one of the country's
leading black newspapers,
declared "intolerance
received one of the
heaviest blows of the ages
on Easter Sunday.
A huge crowd estimated
at 75,000 persons,
as varicolored as the
Easter season itself,
paid homage to a great
singer in a scene
which in its symbolism
and poignancy
surpassed any words that
might be used to describe it.
All seemed to mingle
with one common interest,
the determination to
welcome the greatest
singer of this generation and
to show that tolerance lives."
Anderson's concert was
broadcast nationally,
thus heard by millions,
and it was also filmed.
Here is a clip of her
elegantly claiming
the status of a
diva in a mink coat,
singing "America the Beautiful."
She approaches it like an
art song with crisp diction,
and it's clear she owns
the song's message.
Her accompanist is the Finnish
pianist and composer Kosti
Vehanen, whom Anderson
worked with until 1940
when World War II drew him home.
The film provides very quick
glimpses is the mixed race
audience.
And you'll notice
that Anderson is
singing at the high end
of her three octave range.
[APPLAUSE]
Genius draws no color lines.
And so it is fitting that Marion
Anderson should raise her voice
in tribute to the noble Lincoln,
who mankind will ever honor.
Miss Marion Anderson.
[MUSIC PLAYING - MARIAN
ANDERSON, "MY COUNTRY,
'TIS OF THEE"]
--[SINGING] My country, 'tis of
thee, sweet land of liberty,
of thee we sing.
Land where my fathers died,
land of the pilgrim's pride,
from every mountain
side, let freedom ring.
-In the mid 1950s, the New
York music critic Hugh Thompson
interviewed Anderson and
asked if the Daughters
of the American Revolution
had ever apologized to her.
She paused.
He recounted, "and a
momentary look in her eyes
told me she still felt
the sting of that insult."
"Not that I was ever
aware of," she said.
Despite her symbolic power
on behalf of civil rights,
Anderson never became an
outspoken racial protester.
But that doesn't mean
she lacked agency
in taking courageous steps.
Rather, her resistance
was performed on stage
with a consistent
assertion of high level
professionalism as her weapon.
Over and over, she
made the choice
to sing in racially-fraught
settings, where she
majestically delivered her art.
Viewed as a whole,
Anderson's career
provides a granular view
of the astounding battle,
the mind-numbing
details that were
involved in maintaining
segregation, and then
dismantling it.
Ticketing and
seating for concerts
moved from
whites-only audiences,
to what was termed
"horizontal segregation,"
with people of color in the back
of the hall and the balcony.
Then came vertical segregation,
with a literal line drawn down
the center of auditoriums
to separate the races.
Hard as it is to grasp today,
the vertical arrangement
was once viewed as
a sign of progress.
In a letter to the New
York Times in 1989,
a man identifying himself
as a tobacco employee who
traveled regularly
through the South,
noted that when the Metropolitan
Opera visited Houston,
people of color were
prohibited from attending.
He described a concert
there by Anderson
with vertical segregation.
"The concert in Houston was
given in the Civic Auditorium
before an audience of 5,000,
approximately one third of them
Negroes.
The house was cut vertically
from top to bottom
with Negroes on all floors,
but occupying the third to one
side of the stage.
When Ms. Anderson made
her first appearance,
she bowed perfunctorily
straight in front of her.
Then turned deliberately
toward those of her own race
and bowed very low and long.
It was the most beautiful
and most queenly
gesture I have ever seen."
And of course, the word
Negro was used commonly
during this period.
You're going to hear it a
lot in quotations today,
and it didn't have the
same stigma as it now does.
Anderson was a hard worker,
giving some 60 concerts
a year at her peak,
with repeated tours
through the South.
In 1950, she spoke of
how it was right for her
to go to the South,
even though it
meant that she traveled
with her own pots and pans
to avoid segregated restaurants,
and even though she often
stayed in private homes.
On almost every trip Anderson
stated, "I give concerts
in places I've
never been before.
And a number of my people
get a great deal more out
of actually seeing
a person than they
do by hearing about
the artist or hearing
the performance on the radio.
Seeing a person, some of
them can be inspired."
As was the case with most
black artists performing
in the South, Anderson
risked facing violence.
After 1951 or so, her
performance contracts
included a clause
prohibiting segregation
in audience seating.
Enforcing that clause
brought difficulties,
and her manager, Sol
Hurok, stood firm.
As one example,
Anderson gave back
to back concerts in Jacksonville
and Miami in January of 1952.
And because of her
contract clause,
audiences were
reportedly integrated
for the first time in the
state, albeit contentiously so.
The events put Anderson on
the cover of Jet magazine.
Although both programs
went off without incident
Ms. Anderson received the
largest police protection
ever given an artist in Miami.
50 plainclothes officers,
including FBI agents,
circulated constantly
through the audience.
The article goes on to
note that the KKK held
what was termed a
"routine meeting" outside
of Jacksonville during
Anderson's performance there.
Studying Marian
Anderson in relation
to institutional
segregation means
probing a complex network
of racial and performance
challenges.
Obviously, the
question of geography
was central, with the South
yielding the most problems.
But the urban North also
had its Jim Crow practices,
and so here are some
of the issues involved.
For one thing, Anderson
faced strong opinions
from both blacks and
whites about the race
of her accompanist and
how she would interact
with that person on stage.
She had three main accompanists
over the course of her career,
and all were male.
The first was William
King, known as Billy,
who was from Anderson's
hometown of Philadelphia.
King accompanied
Anderson for her debut
at the New York
stadium concerts,
and they worked
together until she
began making extended trips
to Europe in the late 1920s
and the 1930s.
Before then, a large percentage
of Anderson's engagements
came from black venues and
community organizations.
While in Europe, Anderson
began collaborating
with Kosti Vehanan.
And when Sol Hurok took
over her management in 1935,
he persuaded her to
continue working with Kosti
when she returned to
the United States.
This meant ending her
partnership with William King,
which was fraught to do.
It also raised concerns
about performing
with a white pianist
in US concerts,
sponsored, quote,
"under Negro auspices,"
as Anderson wrote to Claude
Barnett of the Associated Negro
Press in 1935.
The ANP was a black
news syndicate.
Later, when Anderson began
working with the German emigre
Franz Rupp, the two often
shook hands or even held hands
while taking bows, as is
traditional for performers
within the European
concert tradition.
Objections were raised
in some American cities
about interracial touching,
but the two stood firm.
And Rupp was the one who
usually made a genial, but clear
statement to the press.
Another issue had to do
with the racial heritage
of the music being performed.
In her programming,
Anderson consistently
followed the model of her
black predecessors, especially
Henry T. Burleigh
and Roland Hayes,
by opening with European
repertory, usually
a balance of opera,
arias, and art songs,
and ending with concert
arrangements of what were then
called Negro spirituals.
This program, from an
NAACP sponsored concert
in West Virginia
in the late 1930s,
illustrates the standard format.
Two of the arrangers listed
there were African American,
Burleigh and Florence Price.
The spirituals constituted a
kind of political statement,
asserting that this repertory
identified with slavery
deserved an equal status
with revered works
from the Austro-German
tradition.
Yet Anderson's
renditions of spirituals
faced racialized
expectations, with her viewers
and the white press
often seeming preoccupied
by the spirituals
while paying less
attention to the other
repertory she performed.
The racial assumptions
could be crude.
For example, after a recital
at New York City's Town Hall
in 1935, an event
billed as her homecoming
after four years
of working abroad,
a critic for the New
York Herald Tribune
called spirituals "the most
thrilling work" on her recital.
He continued, "these
the singer wisely
did not attempt to sing in
the manner of an art song,
but rather a musical reflection
of indigenous attributes."
What does that mean?
[LAUGHTER]
-In 1943, the composer and
critic Virgil Thompson,
known for his arch
pronouncements that
often carried a sting, wrote
that "when Anderson gets down
to singing in her own
language, the religious music
of her own people,
that is where she
leaves off being a lovely
icicle and becomes a flame."
In the face of such
comments, Anderson
could have avoided
the spirituals.
Instead, she doubled down,
continuing over the decades
to assert the repertory
as a central part
of her artistic identity.
To sample this aspect
of Anderson's legacy,
here she is performing "He's Got
the Whole World in His Hands,"
which is among her core works.
The arrangement is
by Hamilton Forrest.
Franz Rupp is at the
piano, and the performance
was recorded around 1950.
Anderson performed the
same spiritual at the March
on Washington in 1963.
It's not great film quality,
but you get the idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING -
MARIAN ANDERSON,
"HE'S GOT THE WHOLE
WORLD IN HIS HANDS"]
--[SINGING] He's got the
whole world in his hands.
He's got the world in his hands.
He's got the wide
world in his hands.
He's got the whole
He's got the wind and
the rain in his hands.
He's got the sun and the
moonlight in his hands.
He's got the wind and
the rain in his hands.
He's got the whole
world in his hands.
He's got the light.
-Franz Rupp was a
fine accompanist,
as I'm sure you can hear.
Yet another racial
issue had to do
with Hurok Attractions,
Andersen's management from 1935
on, which had to adapt from
the habits of only representing
white artists.
They'd only had one artist
of color before her,
and it was not someone with
the same impact and breadth
of career.
This affected many details
of putting on concerts,
including the need for a mixed
race network for promotion
and newspaper criticism.
For example, there
was the question
of who should be
offered press passes.
Claude Barnett of the
Associated Negro Press
took up the battle, writing to
Hurok's office in January 1936.
So this is at the very
beginning of the time
when Anderson worked with Hurok.
That Anderson's recent
concert, the ANP's New York
representative, quote, "was
not accorded the courtesies
which one of his
standing and capability
had a right to expect."
To its credit, the Hurok
agency regrouped immediately,
asking for the names
of ANP correspondents
who were assigned to
New York concerts.
And they followed through.
Finally, Anderson
and Hurok had to cope
with the racial policies and
practices of the country's most
illustrious concert facilities.
Earlier I mentioned a pair
of incidents in Florida.
But segregation wasn't always
so clear cut in New York City.
Town Hall had a strong
history of featuring
performers of color.
Other facilities were also open,
albeit often with limitations.
Here was a fundamental
issue for Anderson.
There was a basic difference
between renting a facility
rather than being hired by its
most prominent and eponymous
performance organization, which
leads us to Marian Anderson's
debut with the Metropolitan
Opera in January 1955.
It was the second most
famous event in her career.
And it was just as
momentous for the Met,
ending a 75 year history
of racial exclusion.
In histories of the
Metropolitan Opera,
there's a gaping silence about
the company's racial practices.
Anderson's debut
is routinely noted
as a positive development,
but the long period
in which the company practiced
a whites-only policy is ignored.
The silence was established
in part by the white press.
Black newspapers, by contrast,
decried the company repeatedly
over the decades.
In 1944, for example,
Baltimore's Afro-American
excoriated the Met for what it
called "an Aryans-only policy."
And for those of you
who are historians
in archival research,
you know that it's only
within the last 10 to 15 years
that black newspapers have been
digitized, which has
transformed everything
in terms of doing the kind of
research I'm now involved in.
Civil rights historians
talk about studying a nation
within a nation when
they study black culture.
And musically, that's as true
as it is in any other dimension.
So for me, the black
newspapers are really
crucial to flip a perspective
on classical music performance
by artists of color.
With the Met, racial
change came about through
a protracted effort on the part
of civil rights organizations,
black newspapers, and
progressive whites
in positions of power.
In Anderson's case, the latter
included Sol Hurok and Howard
Taubman of the New York Times,
who grew increasingly outspoken
as the years passed.
As a result, Anderson's
debut at the Met
didn't appear as a
magical change in attitude
on the part of the
company, but rather
was the result of a
multi-year lobbying
campaign, a breakthrough
that occurred
when she was 58 years old,
past the prime of any singer.
Beginning in April
1943, just a few years
after Anderson's triumph
at the Lincoln Memorial,
she began asserting her
presence on the Met stage.
To challenge the opera
company's racial exclusions,
Sol Hurok instead made
the symbolic gesture
of renting the hall,
with Anderson physically
occupying it and
filling the house
with her glorious voice in spite
of the company's prejudices.
She consistently
packed the place,
which could hold an
audience of nearly 4,000.
And this was the old Met on
Broadway between 39th and 40th.
The Metropolitan Opera
House at Lincoln Center
didn't open until 1966,
and when that happened,
this building was torn down.
In 1943, the same year
as Anderson's first solo
concert on the Met
stage, Howard Taubman
published a book for fans
of classical music titled,
Music on My Beat: An
Intimate Volume of Shop Talk.
In chapter 15, titled
"The Negro in Music,"
Taubman let loose, articulating
racial realities that were not
otherwise being
widely acknowledged
among white readers
and audiences.
"How can we expect a hospitable
approach to the Negro musician
from the Metropolitan Opera
House when some of its patrons
will not even tolerate
the presence of a Negro
in an adjacent seat?
At a recent opening
at the Metropolitan,
several Negroes, dressed
in white tie and tails
like the other customers,
occupied $10 seats.
Some subscribers whose
seats adjoined those held
by the Negroes were annoyed.
They complained
to the box office,
which explained that
the seats were purchased
through speculators,
for the box office
has to be tender about the
prejudices of its quality
trade.
If Negro customers buy tickets
directly from the box office,
precautions are taken
to give them aisle seats
and to tear up the ticket
for the adjoining seat,
so that no white
patron will have
to rub shoulders with a Negro.
Even when business is good,
this practice is followed.
An opera official
explained with a long face
that the sacrifice
had to be made."
Taubman continued, "but
with unchanging bigotries
in the paying
customers, how can we
expect essentially
conservative institutions
like the Metropolitan Opera,
or the New York Philharmonic
Symphony Orchestra,
to invite Negroes
who become members of singing
or playing personnel?"
Taubman later was
the ghost writer
for Anderson's autobiography,
My Lord, What a Morning,
which appeared in 1956.
Anderson's campaign
at the Met continued,
and she was back on stage
in 1945 and 1946, again
with concerts on Sunday
afternoons in April.
Then in 1947, Hurok
landed the booking
he must have been
aiming for all along.
Not only was Anderson's
rental of the Met in April,
but it took place
on Easter, which
then became an annual event.
It was a brilliant stroke.
Anderson's triumph at
the Lincoln Memorial had,
of course, occurred
on Easter Sunday.
And her standing room
concerts at the Met
identified her
even more intensely
with a symbolism of that
day, with hope and renewal,
with the possibility of
triumphing over tragedy,
with Christian goodness.
Most of those
attending the concert
were members of her own race,
New York's Amsterdam News,
a black newspaper observed
after Anderson's Easter concert
in 1947.
"Mr. Hurok's office informed
me," the reporter continued,
"that advertisement
had purposely
been released in
the Negro papers
first so no one could say there
was partiality of any kind."
Anderson also presented
Easter concerts at the Met
in 1948 and 1949.
Then in May, 1950, she
sailed on the Queen Elizabeth
for a concert tour of
Europe and South America.
And Rudolf Bing, the recently
appointed General Director
of the Metropolitan Opera
Company, was on board as well.
That same year, Anderson
made another strategic move,
releasing her first
recording of opera duets
together with Jan Pearce,
a tenor at the Met.
Rudolph Bing's appointment
made a difference,
as did the leadership of Max
Rudolf, the Met's conductor
at the time.
Both were European.
Bing was Viennese born
and a British national,
while Rudolf had
emigrated from Germany.
In 1951, the Met's color
line started to waver,
even as an incremental
campaign intensified
to remake the company
into a desegregated
artistic and social space.
On January 21st, Duke
Ellington and his orchestra
presented a benefit concert
for the NAACP at the Met
with a strategically chosen
group of prominent supporters.
Once again, gifted performers
of color occupied the hall.
Mrs. Vincent Impellitteri, wife
of the mayor of New York City,
served as hostess.
And Marian Anderson was
one of the chairwomen.
In March, Fred Thomas,
a young black baritone,
from Norristown,
Pennsylvania, was
among three winners of the
Metropolitan Opera's Auditions
of the Air, a contest
with 700 entrants.
And around the same
time, a reporter
from the American Negro
Press sent questions
to the Met's popular opera quiz,
asking when the company would
hire a black artist.
In October, a
significant breakthrough
occurred when the Met signed
the African-American ballerina
Janet Collins as one of
its two premiere dancers.
The Pittsburgh Courier,
a black newspaper,
declared that "a long and
bitter fight has been carried on
for over 10 years for such
an opportunity in the world's
most famous opera house."
In November, the New
York Post reported,
"for the first time in the
history of the Metropolitan
Opera House's dressy
openings, Negroes
were admitted last night to
the swanky Sherry's Bar, where
society and cafe society
relax at intermissions.
Marian Anderson, the famous
singer, was one of the Negroes
served, but not the first."
That same month,
four black singers
appeared in the chorus
of Cavalleria rusticana,
thus managing to quote,
"break the Aida pattern,"
as another black paper,
the Atlanta Daily World.
"To date, Aida has been
the only operatic vehicle
in which most Negro
singers were featured,"
the article continued.
In 1953, Robert McFerrin became
the first African American
to win the Metropolitan
Opera of the Air Auditions.
Then in 1954, Sylvia Olden
Lee became the first African
American on the Met staff.
A brilliant pianist
and vocal coach,
Lee became the coach to multiple
generations of Met singers,
including Shirley
Verrett, Kathleen Battle,
and Jessye Norman.
The biggest breakthrough of
all occurred that October
when Bing signed Anderson
to appear with the Met
the following January.
Anderson noted in an interview
that the Supreme Court
ruling in Brown v.
Board of Education
had taken place that May.
And quote, "it gives
the feeling that they
are beginning to understand,
to know that you're there."
Anderson's actual debut
on January 7th, 1955,
was a major cultural event,
with heavy attendance
by African Americans,
including many
who had traveled from
all over the country.
"Hired Cadillacs deposited
parties from Harlem,"
declared the
Associated Negro Press.
"And it was sheer
delight to see parties
of lovely teenage girls
chaperoned by their elders
taking their seats."
Plus, two porters at the
Met purchased tickets
and proudly entered as guests.
Prominent figures turned out,
including Langston Hughes
and an impressive array
of black vocalists,
Roland Hayes, Eva Jessye,
conducted the chorus
of the original Porgy and
Bess, Mattiwilda Dobbs,
who was the first black singer
to debut at La Scala, Leontyne
Price, and Camilla Williams
and Lawrence Winters,
who were then featured artists
with the New York City Opera.
Founded in 1943, the
New York City Opera
had broken the
color line in 1946.
Here is an excerpt of Marian
Anderson and the recording
of Masked Ball, made
immediately after her premiere.
[MUSIC PLAYING - MARIAN
ANDERSON, "MASKED BALL"]
-[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
-While it is tempting to end
this tale on a triumphal note,
which has frequently been the
case in historical narratives,
the sobering reality
is that Anderson
was asked to play a character
rife with longstanding racial
stereotypes and ties
to the tradition
of blackface minstrelsy.
Her role was that of Ulrica
in Verdi's Masked Ball,
an opera seldom
performed at the time.
When the opera was composed
in the mid-19th century,
the original
location of the plot
was changed from Sweden
to colonial Boston.
In a recent article, one
scholar of Italian history
has called the
revised opera, quote,
"a remarkably painful
theatrical representation
of life in the New World."
There, Ulrica Rieger is
described in the libretto
as possessing, quote, "the
foul blood of the Negroes."
In the 19th century, Ulrica
played by a white singer
in blackface, even as Harriet
Beecher Stowe's Uncle Tom's
Cabin generated considerable
discussion in Italy.
While Ulrica sings in
only one scene which
takes place in Act One,
when Marian Anderson
took the stage she was
attired in a long, black wig,
waved a skull and
crossbones, and stirred
an immense cauldron.
She was a fearful character,
one observer noted.
Another commented on the
contrast to the evening gowns
she wears in recitals.
Only a few cultural
critics at the time
connected the dots between
the exotic othering of Ulrica
and that of Marian Anderson.
The notion of colorblind
casting as we conceive it today
barely existed.
And the practices of
blackface were alive and well
on stage and screen.
Among those alert to
racial representation
was Dean Gordon Hancock of
the American Negro Press
who wrote an article immediately
after Anderson's premiere
highlighting the implications
of what had transpired.
"It is interesting to note
here that this opera originally
called for a Negro as
Ulrica, and in addition,
gives some conception
of the light
in which the Negro race was
held in Italy prior to 1859.
For the judge in
addressing Ricardo, says,
'Ulrica, she is of the vile
race of Negroes.'" Hancock
continued.
Of course, she
says it in Italian,
which in New York City, maybe
people didn't notice as much.
"Curiously, Anderson
was playing two roles,
a member of the vile race of
Negroes, and an arch pioneer
in finally bringing democracy
to an operatic institution
of which all Americans
should be unanimously proud."
Anderson performed
Ulrica six times
on the stage of the old
Metropolitan Opera House,
and two of those performances
were featured in the company's
radio broadcasts.
For Anderson, there
was no opportunity
for a career in opera.
Rather, she used her celebrity
to crack open a door that
had previously been unmovable.
A string of Met debuts followed
by African-American singers,
including Robert McFerrin in
Aida, on January 27, 1955,
three weeks after
Anderson's breakthrough,
Mattiwilda Dobbs, in
Rigoletto in 1956,
and Gloria Davy in Aida in 1958.
The Met debut of Leontyne
Price in 1961 in Trovatore
marked the biggest
advance of all.
Price became a central
member of the company
rather than an artist
featured only a few times.
My research this
year at Radcliffe
is dedicated to
exploring threads
of this sort in the history
of racial desegregation
in American performance.
And I want to conclude today
by looping back to the press
release about the new $5 bill,
which used the term "opera
singer," and also to
Newsweek's recent question,
"who is Marian Anderson?"
With the press release, the
Secretary of the Treasury
must have deployed "opera"
for its cultural cache,
intending it as a complement
to Anderson, as a validation.
Yet given the pernicious
exclusion of her
from opera stages, it's
poignant if not painful
to associate her with the
status that she was, in fact,
prevented from achieving.
Meanwhile, Newsweek's headline
exposes the enormous gaps
in historical memory about
on the ground realities
of racial segregation
and about the spectrum
of figures who played a role
in the Civil Rights Movement.
To move forward as a
multiracial citizenry,
we need to do better.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]